when you build systems AI systems that
play these games we'll talk about poker
we'll talk about diplomacy
are you
um are you drawn in in part by the
beauty of the game itself AI aside or is
it to you primarily a fascinating
problem set for the AI to solve I'm
drawn in by the beauty of the game uh
when I I started playing poker when I
was in high school and the idea to me
that there is a correct and objectively
correct way of playing poker and if you
could figure out what that is then
you're you know you're making unlimited
money basically that's like a really
fascinating concept to me
um and so I was fascinated by the
strategy of Poker even when I was like
16 years old it wasn't until like much
later that I actually worked on poker
AIS so there was a sense that you can
solve poker like uh in the way you can
solve chess for example or checkers
I believe Checkers got solved right yeah
Checkers Checkers is completely solved
optimal straps optimal strategy it's
impossible to beat the AI yeah and so in
that same way you could technically
solve chess
you could solve chess you could solve
poker you could solve poker so this is
this gets into the concept of an ash
equilibrium yeah so it is a Nash
equilibrium Okay so
and any finite two-player zero-sum game
there is an optimal strategy that if you
play it you are guaranteed to not lose
an expectation no matter what your
opponent does
and this is kind of a radical concept to
a lot of people
um but it's true in chess it's true in
poker it's true in any finite two-player
zero-sum game and to give some intuition
for this you can think of rock paper
scissors
in rock paper scissors if you randomly
choose between throwing rock paper and
scissors with equal probability then no
matter what your opponent does you are
not going to lose an expectation you're
not going to lose an expectation in the
long run
now the same is true for poker there
exists some strategy some really
complicated strategy that if you play
that you are guaranteed to not lose
money in the long run and I should say
this is for two player poker six player
poker is a different story yeah it's a
beautiful giant mess when you say in
expectation you're guaranteed not to
lose in expectation what does in
expectation mean Poker is a very high
variance game so you're gonna have hands
where you win you're gonna have hands
with your lose even if you're playing
the perfect strategy you can't guarantee
they're going to win every single hand
but if you play for long enough then you
are guaranteed to at least break even
and and practice probably one
so that's an expectation the size of
your stack generally speaking now that
doesn't include anything about the fact
that you can go broke it doesn't include
any of those kinds of normal real world
limitations you're talking you know in
the theoretical world
uh what about this the zero-sum aspect
how big of a constraint is that how big
of a constraint is finite
so
finite's not a huge constraint so I mean
most games that you play are finite in
size
um it's also true actually that there
exists this like perfect strategy in
many infinite games as well technically
the game has to be compact
um there are like some edge cases where
you don't have an ash equilibrium and a
two player zero-sum game so you can
think of a game where you like you know
if we're playing a game where whoever
names the bigger number is the winner
there's no Nash equilibrium to that game
17 yeah 18. about you beat you win again
you're good at this I played a lot of
games
okay uh so that's and then the Zero Sum
aspect the zero zero sum aspects so
there exists a Nash equilibrium in non
two player zero-sum games as well and by
the way just to clarify what I mean by
two player Zero Sum I mean there's two
players and whatever one player wins the
other player loses so if we're applying
poker and I win 50 that means that
you're losing fifty dollars
now outside of two player zero-sum games
there still exists Nash equilibria but
they're not as meaningful
because you know you can think of a game
like Risk
if everybody else at the and on the
board decides a team up against you and
take you out there's no perfect strategy
you can play that's gonna guarantee that
you win there there's just nothing you
can do so outside of two players zero
some games there's no guarantee that
you're going to win by playing a
national equilibrium
have you ever tried to model in the
other aspects of the game which is like
the pleasure you draw from playing the
game and then if you're a professional
poker player if you're exciting even if
you lose
uh the you know the money you would get
from the attention you get to the
sponsor and all that kind of stuff is
that that would be a fun thing to model
to model in as I'd be make it sort of
super complex to include the human
factor in this in this full complexity I
think you bring up a couple good points
there so I think a lot of professional
poker players I mean they got a huge
amount of money not from actually
playing poker but from the sponsorships
and having a personality that people
want to tune in and watch that that's a
big that's a big way to to make a name
for yourself in poker I just wanted from
an AI perspective if you create and
we'll talk about this more maybe a AI
system that also talks trash and all
that kind of stuff that that becomes
part of the function to maximize so it's
not just optimal poker play maybe
sometimes you want to be chaotic maybe
sometimes you want to be suboptimal and
you lose
um the the chaos and maybe sometimes you
want to be overly aggressive because
people the audience loves that
that's fascinating I think I think what
you're getting at here is that there's a
difference between making an AI that
wins a game and an AI That's fun to play
with right yeah yeah and more fun to
watch so those are all different things
fun to play with and fun to watch yeah
and I think you know I've I've heard uh
talks from like game designers and and
they say like you know people that work
on AI for actual recreational games that
people play and they say yeah there's a
big difference between trying to make an
air that actually wins and you know you
look at a game like Civilization
um the way that the AIS play is not
optimal for trying to win they're
they're playing a different game they're
trying to have personalities they're
trying to be fun and engaging
um and that makes for a better game yeah
and we also talk about NPCs I just
talked to Todd Howard who is the the
creator of Fallout in the Elder Scrolls
series and
um Starfield the new game coming out and
the Creator what I think is the greatest
game of all time which is Skyrim and the
NPCs there the AI that governs that
whole game is very interesting but the
NPCs also are super interesting and
considering what language models might
do to NPCs in an open world RPG
role-playing game
it's super exciting yeah honestly I'm I
think this is like one of the first
applications where we're going to see
like real consumer interaction with
large language models
um I guess what sky um Elder Scrolls 6
is in development now they're probably
like pretty close to finishing it but I
would not be surprised at all if Elder
Scrolls 7 was using large language
models for their NPCs no they're not
they're I mean I'm not saying anything
not saying anything this is me
speculating not you no but but there's
they're just releasing the star feel
good they do one game at a time yeah and
so uh whatever it is whenever the date
is I don't know what the data is calm
down uh but it would be I don't know
like uh 20 24 25 26 so it's actually
very possible they would include
language models I was listening to this
um this talk by a gaming executive uh
when I was in grad school
and one of the questions that a person
in the audience asked is why are all
these games so focused on fighting and
killing and the person responded that
it's just so much harder to make an AI
that can talk with you and cooperate
with you than it is to make an AI that
can fight you
and I think once this technology
develops further and you can have a you
can reach a point where like not every
single line of dialogue has to be
scripted it unlocks a lot of potential
for new kinds of games like much more
like positive interactions that are not
so focused on fighting and I'm really
looking forward to that well it might
not be positive it might be just drama
you'll be in like a Call of Duty game
instead of doing the shooting you'll
just be hanging out and like arguing
with an AI about like
um like passive aggressive and then you
won't be able to sleep that night you
have to return or continue the argument
that you're uh emotionally hurt uh
I mean yeah I think that's actually an
exciting World whatever whatever is the
drama the chaos that we love the push
and pull of human connection I think
it's possible to do that in the video
game world and I think you could be
Messier and make more mistakes in the
Video Game World which is why it would
be a nice place and and also it doesn't
have a deep of a as deep of a real
psychological impact because inside
video games it's kind of understood that
you're in a not a real world so whatever
crazy stuff AI does we have some
flexibility to play just like with the
game of diplomacy it's a game this is
not real geopolitics not real war it's a
it's a game so you could you can have a
little bit of fun
um a little bit of chaos okay back to
Natural uh how do we find the Nash
equilibrium
all right so there's different ways to
find an ash equilibrium so um
the way that we do it is with this
process called self-play
um basically we have this algorithm that
starts by playing totally randomly and
it learns how to play the game by
playing against itself
so
um it will start playing the game
totally randomly and then it you know if
it's playing poker it'll eventually like
get to the end of the end of the game
and make fifty dollars
and then it will like review all the
decisions that it made along the way and
say what would have happened if I had
chosen this other action instead you
know if I had raised here instead of
called
um what would the other player have done
and because it's playing against a copy
of itself it's able to do that
counterfactual reasoning so they can say
okay well if I took this action and the
other person takes this action and then
I take this action and eventually I make
150 instead of 50.
and so it updates the regret value for
that action
regret is basically like how much does
it regret having not played that action
in the past
and when it encounters that same
situation again it's going to pick
actions that have higher regret with
higher probability
now
it'll just keep simulating the games
this way it'll keep um you know
accumulating regrets for different
situations
um and in the long run if you pick
actions that have higher regret with
higher probability in the correct way
it's proven to converge to a Nash
equilibrium
even for super complex games even for
imperfect information games it's true
for all games it's true for it's true
for chess it's true for poker it's
particularly useful for poker so this is
the the method of contractual regret
minimization this is counter factual
regret minimization that doesn't have to
do with self-play has to do with just
any any if you follow this kind of
process self-play or not you'll be able
to arrive at an optimal set of actions
so this counterfactual regret
minimization is a kind of self-play it's
a principled kind of self-play that's
proven to converge to Nash equilibria
even in in perfect information games now
you can have other forms of self-play
and people use other forms of self-play
for perfect information games
um where you have more flexibility the
algorithm doesn't have to be as
theoretically sound in order to converge
to that class of games because there's
uh it's a simpler setting sure so I kind
of in my brain the word self-play has
mapped in you all networks but we're
speaking something bigger than just
neural networks it could be anything
the self-play mechanism is just the
mechanism of a system playing itself
exactly yeah self-play is not tied
specifically to neural Nets it's it's a
kind of reinforcement learning basically
okay and I would also say this process
of like trying to reason oh what would
the value have been if I had taken this
other action instead this is very
similar to how humans learn to play a
game like poker right like you probably
played poker before and with your
friends you probably asked like oh what
do you have called me if I raised there
you know and that's that's a person
trying to do the same kind of like
learning from a counter factual that the
AI is doing okay and if you do that at
scale you're going to be able to learn
an optimal policy yeah now where the
neural nets come in I said like okay if
it's in that situation again then it
will choose the action that has high
regret now the problem is that poker is
such a huge game you know I think no
limit Texas Hold'em the version that we
were playing has 10 to the 161 different
decision points which is more than the
number of atoms in the universe squared
that's heads up that's heads up yeah 10
to the 161 you said yeah I mean it
depends on the number of chips that you
have the stacks and everything but like
the version that we were playing was
tense to the 161. which I assume would
be a somewhat simplified version anyway
because the about there's some like step
function you had for like bets oh no no
that's that's I'm saying like we played
the the full game you can bet whatever
amount you want another thought maybe
was constrained in like what it
considered for bed sizes but the the
person on the other side could bet
whatever they wanted yeah I mean 161
plus or minus 10 doesn't matter yeah
um and so the way neural Nets help out
here is you know you don't have to run
into the same exact situation because
that's never going to happen again the
odds of you running into the same exact
situation are pretty slim but if you run
into a similar situation then you can
generalize from other states that you've
been in that kind of look like that one
and you can say like well these other
situations I had high regret for this
action and so maybe I should play that
action here as well